Welcome to Module Two — neural network fundamentals.
We'll build the network from the ground up: the artificial neuron, activation functions, the forward and backward pass, and the shape of a Keras training loop.
It starts with the perceptron — a single neuron.
It weights its inputs, sums them, adds a bias, and passes the result through an activation.
On its own it can only draw a straight line, so it can't even solve XOR.
But stack neurons into hidden layers, and a multi-layer perceptron becomes a universal function approximator.
The activation is what gives the network its power.
Sigmoid and tanh saturate and choke the gradient.
ReLU is the cheap, sparse workhorse you'll reach for by default, and GELU is a smoother cousin popular in Transformers.
Pick the activation and the initializer together — He for ReLU.
So how does it learn?
The forward pass computes a loss from the inputs and the current weights.
The backward pass walks the chain rule in reverse, where each layer contributes a local Jacobian — really just a matrix multiply.
The optimizer then nudges every weight, and GradientTape makes that whole tape visible when you need to debug it.
In Keras you'll meet two front doors to the same engine.
The Sequential API stacks layers in a line — fastest to prototype.
The Functional API builds arbitrary graphs with multiple inputs and outputs.
And subclassing the Model gives you full research freedom.
One last thing makes deep networks actually trainable: normalize your inputs to mean zero and unit variance, let batch norm steady the activations in between, and match your initializer to your activation — because bad initialization is exactly how gradients vanish or explode.
Let's build your first MLP — open the labs.